philipp amthor fragt sich wo
ja das ist in der tat eine frage die
sich dieser tage aufdrängt wo ist
eigentlich olaf scholz in den vielen
debatten die wir im parlament führen ist
zwar körperlich anwesend aber er äußert
sich nicht in der debatte um die
impfpflicht kein gesetzentwurf und
besonders frappierend heute im zur lage
in der berliner loki eine
regierungserklärung kein wort es wird
debattiert über das programm mit den
deutschen g7 präsidentschaft kein wort
von olaf scholz soll die werbung schon
zu ende ich finde es ist nicht die
werbung die hier zu ende ist und dann
ist ein ernsthaftes thema und ich finde
als vizepräsident des parlaments könnte
ihnen auch am herzen liegen dass der
bundeskanzler auch in der mitte des
parlaments debattiert die lage in der
ukraine
da schauen alle auf deutschland alle
fragen sich wie positioniert sich
deutschland in dieser lage es brauchte
cdu und csu in diese debatte zu
beantragen friedrich merz hat heute eine
gute rede gehalten führung gezeigt vom
bundeskanzler hören wir im parlament
nichts und ich erwarte dass er im
parlament dazu stellung bezieht und sich
nicht wegduckt und deswegen ist die
frage wo es um abseits die berechtigte
frage an der unsere jürges weiß wohl auf
scholz ist oder wo ja moment auch
international unterwegs und zwar gerade
in der frage soll im parlament seien
auch soldaten lernen ich habe mir
gestern diese debatte orientierungs
debatte über die impfpflicht angehört
das ist dem deutschen noch ein stückchen
näher als die ukraine lage ja wohl
nachts doch aber nicht mehr um neben dem
moment nein das macht es nicht ich will
das noch mal zurückgeben und da habe ich
mir angeguckt wer redet da eigentlich
und wenn wolfgang kubicki nicht
derjenige gewesen wäre der als der als
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender
dort eine rede gehalten welt zu sein
antrag hat er den werbeblocker der cdu
ich würde oder satz war noch nicht zu
ende dann hätte außer den afc führern
kein partei- oder fraktionschef dort
eine rede gehalten und die ihr habt alle
eure gesundheitspolitiker ins rennen
geschickt bei dieser wichtigen frage und
die parteiführer und fraktions wir haben
sich alle bedeckt gehalten aus
taktischen gründen mal abwarten wie der
hase läuft aber die gesundheitspolitiker
das konnte man deutlich sehen war
gestern als friedrich merz exakt
friedrich merz hat es für mich gerade
werden aber man muss nicht mehr zahlen
den schwerpunkt gesetzt in dieser woche
die ukraine und die auch den
fraktionsvorsitz zu übernehmen und ralph
brinkhaus zur seite zu platzieren hat
das ist eine neue spectors bringen so
dass sie mich noch einmal die daten
trotzdem zweifel ja auch nicht die
opposition wann der kanzler wozu redet
sondern die regierung das war übrigens
bei angela merkel genauso gab viele
fragen irgendwas anlage stellen müssen
angela merkel außenpolitik hat die
kanzlerin im parlament immer
klarstellung gut das lager das nachher
bratislava daran dass der amtierende
große koalition dazu eine niederlage war
ja das ist ja jetzt ganz anders nicht
als die außenministerin das hat ja auch
die union mittlerweile erkannt macht ja
im ausland und auch hier eine
respektable figur von mir aus sogar über
meine erwartungen habe hier annalena
baerbock auch schon jetzt sicher ob man
bis jetzt dass ich ganz toll
aber er hat sich nicht gezahlt um beim
thema zu bleiben also wenn man sich als
auch in den vergangenen tagen die medien
anschaut zum beispiel die zeit heute in
einem großen essay über das was im
urlaub macht oder nicht macht dann ist
ja schon zu erkennen dass der vorwurf so
ein bisschen ist olaf scholz will so
bleiben wie vorher er kommt nicht so
richtig aus der deckung er antwortet
nicht auf fragen konkret insbesondere in
interviews er ist zeigt kann klartext
erst bei vielen fragen ausweichen
impfpflicht ukraine ganz ganz viele
themen herr kubicki sie sind doch im
klartext politiker erwarten sich
eigentlich auch mal dass ihr kanzler ist
es ja jetzt in ihrer koalition auf den
tisch haut und sagt da gehen wir an im
gegensatz zu ihnen habe ich ein anderes
demokratieverständnis das besteht darin
dass nicht wir einen haben der sagt wo
es lang geht sondern dass wir führung
durch überzeugung die generieren nicht
durch anordnung das unterscheidet ja für
diese regierung das video von der
letzten argumente hätten ja außerdem
überhaupt nicht mehr gebraucht sonst
nach auffassung von einander hier ist
hat er hier ist es hier sind sodass ich
weiß die regierung und zwar in allen
ihren facetten nach außen wahrnehmbar
ist sowohl in der ukraine krise durch
einen der berge ziemlich klaren worten
nicht wie auch fröhlich merz heute
eingestanden hat in der finanzpolitik
durch christian lindner und wenn es
drauf ankommt wird er kannst du das
sagen aber es gibt keinen grund sagt
olaf scholz bilder ist jetzt und deshalb
passiert es so dass war 16 jahre cdu
politiker
die in einer arbeitsfähigen koalition ok
new york ist kennt wahrscheinlich oder
hat die meisten kanzlerinnen kanzler in
den letzten jahren intensiv begleitet
für den stern immer wieder von ganz ganz
nahe wie bewertest du olaf scholz
bisheriges auf fahrräder sechsmal sollen
wir uns erinnern dass angela merkel auch
immer wieder phasen hatte wo die medien
geschrieben haben was denkt sie
eigentlich wo ist überhaupt das ist der
höchste zeit dass ich mal dazu was hast
du dich einmal gefordert und dann
hab ich habe angela merkel ja das ist ja
immer wieder vorgehalten worden
spezifikum von medien die wollen leben
auf der bühne haben und wenn da sich
einer nicht zeigt dann sind sie
enttäuscht ich finde dass ermüdend das
haben die medien irgendwann angefangen
in einer stadt vom anderen ab weil das
ist jetzt so die quelle die die die
dieser bereits relativ viele interviews
geführt aber bild ja es sind sagt aber
nicht will da ist wie angela merkel ich
fand zunächst mal
positiv das ehrt dieser hysterie welle
in der krone politik entgegen getreten
ist wie die gesamte koalition das war
ins land die fdp aber auch schon aus
stolz denn wir hätten sonst schon unter
etwa die wähler unter führung der cdu
mit herrn brown hätten wir längst wieder
ein lockdown gehabt und zwar um die
weihnachtszeit und zwar mit karacho weil
da
nicht so schwarz weißen auch nicht doch
das ist genau das ist ein anderes thema
aber dass ein gewichtiges da hat er sich
groß raus gewagt und jetzt wird sich
daran auch nicht mehr messen wie sich
jetzt zeigt ist dieser kurs in sachen
impfpflicht und corona politik verkehrt
er muss drauf gucken was sein minister
treibt und der tat ganz gute sachen und
es wird höchste zeit dass das helfen
soll haben wir verstanden
ich höre und seinen jungstar ja wirklich
auch jetzt schreien amthor sind sie für
die impfpflicht ist die union für die
impfpflicht stimmen sie für die eu sowie
lage also oder schreien sie jetzt hier
nur um erklären
für die empfindliche oder kubicki zur
wahrheit gehört dass unser stimmungsbild
innerhalb der fraktion auch
unterschiedlich fragt doch sie
persönlich habe eine eher skeptische
haltung mit blick auf die erst mal
butter bei die fische am zeug ja oder
nein ich habe dann aber ja oder nein
aber ich habe mir lange frage ja ja oder
nein die ist so einfach ist dort nicht
sozialen war ich ja oder nein doch er
geht um die frage der vollzieht das
wieder ein vollstrecker es geht um die
frage ab wann die frage ob sie gerne
sind wir müssen dafür eine grundlage
schaffen und vor allem müssen wir und
das finde ich ist ein richtiges ziel in
der fraktion zu einer position kommen
hört ich glaube ihr macht es euch laden
zur in dem ihr werk am gegeben es ist
doch
ich bin einfach ich glaub wenn sie für
eine inflation oder shops unterstützen
wenn sie gegen eine flut sind müssen sie
mich unterstützen auch da können sie
sich jetzt entscheiden sind sie für
einen da müssen sie doch gesagt stasi
schaltet ich sage ja schon gesagt wir
wollen schalten also ich finde von der
sache die argumente die sie zum beispiel
gegen eine impfpflicht vorbringen finde
ich persönlich sehr plausibel aber ich
sage auch ich gebe das ziel nicht auf
dass wir in der fraktion eine
einheitliche positionierung dazu finden
und das ist auch genau das richtige und
kämpfe ich kämpfe ich ja der fraktion
für oder gegen eine impfpflicht ich bin
offen dafür mich überzeugen zu lassen
frage aber kämpfen ja ich sage
jedenfalls ohne ein ins register und
ohne praktische vorgaben wie man diese
impfpflicht vollzieht werde ich eine
helmpflicht nichts absätze des polit
theater sozusagen zwischen cdu und fdp
kubicki sie sind ja einer der anführer
kann man sagen der anti allgemeine
impfpflicht bewegung wenn sie hier was
ich aber nicht viel wohler scholz geht
das verstehe ich in der sache der dass
es keinen sinn dass das weiß glaube ich
auch jeder zuschauer bei bild sie haben
ja immer klar gegen gesprochen ihre
prognose wird am ende ihre meinung
überzeugen oder die von olaf scholz und
anderen die sagen und braucht diese
pflicht
das kommt auf den zeitablauf anderen wir
wenn wir konkrete gesetzesvorlagen haben
bisher sind das ja nur ankündigungen von
den protagonisten einer impfpflicht ab
18 oder eine pflicht ab 50 dass es ein
gesetzentwurf geben sollte ist noch
nicht ja wenn wir das ende märz
entscheiden dann wird uns die reale
entwicklung weit davon weg bringen das
die mehr des bundestages noch für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 stimmen
wird das muss man wirklich sagen und
selbst wenn das tschuldigung ich glaube
ich glaube momentan ist das
kräfteverhältnis so dass heute stand
heute eine mehrheit des hauses für 15
die stimmen würde das war eine witterung
für eine allgemein üblich wird es
wahrscheinlich keine mehr geben weil die
union sich verrate jetzt nicht ihre
strategie sich darauf eingelassen dazu
sagen wir brauchen er ist ein im
frühling ist da sie wissen das dauert ja
hoffentlich ist das dauert zwei jahres
eingerichtet ist und dann stimmen der
fli zu umgehen viele stimmen zu können
und damit olaf scholz zwingen zu wollen
das ja die politische herangehen zweite
zwingen zu wollen für eine eigene
mehrheit zu sorgen von der herr am tor
weiß dass die fdp hin falls diese
eigenem er nicht herstellen wird und das
ist wie ich finde der sache nicht
angemessen es geht hier wirklich um die
frage wie können wir sinnvollerweise die
menschen erstes mal wieder erreichen und
zwar mit dem panini geschehen fertig
waren es war nicht nehmen das virus
ausrotten sondern wir wirklich lernen
damit zu leben aber es gehe ihnen eine
sachfrage finde ich die wir nach unseren
üblichen regulierungen und vorstellungen
aus diskutieren können und nicht nach
dem modus jeder macht seins ich finde es
kann man eine sache diskutieren und
nicht nur sozusagen nach dieser frage
orientierungs debatte was auch immer da
muss man schon sagen scholz will eine
impfpflicht hat dafür in seiner
regierung keine mehrheit und könnte
versuchen bei uns das ist jetzt viel
klein klein erschien es geht mir gemerkt
als angela merkel die wollte auch der
gott wir haben wir allen belangen
kleiner hat noch einmal gut er gegen
kurze impfpflicht glaubt sein bestes
verlaub bist du am ende dass die
impfpflicht kommen wird oder glaubst du
dass wolfgang mit beginn noch verhindern
weist ja ich dachte wettkampf seit dem
sack ich keine prognosen mehr als ich
hab zu impfpflicht sagen möchte ist
ganz klar in dieser runde generell auch
mal ich finde auch und da bin ich jetzt
auch mal ehrlich wenn man das so
mitbekommt denn dann denkt man sich auch
manchmal als bürger so in meinem kann
eigentlich nicht mehr als ich verstehe
auch viele menschen die nicht mehr
können sich selbst werde manchmal waren
sie nicht selbst nicht nur eine
außengastronomie sitze und mir wieder
jemand sagt die freundin die jetzt
kommen muss man schnelltest machen weil
sie noch nicht gewusst hat ist er lege
ich mich schon wieder auf mein problem
ist nicht mehr aber nicht oder nicht gut
war oder ob jetzt olaf scholz sorry
philipp aber ob olaf scholz gerade
irgendwie weg ist oder ob er wieder da
ist mein problem ist dass wir jetzt
endlich mal ein lichtblick brauchen
england feier zum zweiten mal im film
wäre und ich werde wieder in der
außengastronomie man booster dingen
vorzeigen müssen und ich bin auch
dagegen dass die impfpflicht kommt
deswegen ich kann dich ja jetzt
vielleicht überzeugen und einmal dem
satz wenn du für die impfpflicht stimmst
du stimmst du auch dafür dass ein mensch
nicht überall medizinischen eingriff
entscheiden kann und wenn dann doch ins
nebenwirkungen auftreten sollten ich
finde das geht einfach nicht die
nebenwirkungen sollten wir nicht die
glaube es gibt es objektive kriterien
die darüber entscheiden werden ob es die
impfpflicht geben wird oder nicht mehr
wenn die pandemie zu ende geht und es
wird eine ndr aus und alle maßnahmen
werden zurückgenommen und die leute
können sich frei bewegen wer wollte denn
wo sie müssen also gar kein hindernis
mehr irgendwo zeigen wer will denn da
kontrollieren ob sie jetzt geimpft sind
ja oder nein ein im register gibt es
nicht du musst es einen ausweis gar
nicht bei dir haben
da kommt noch irgendwie in ordnungsamt
in ein restaurant gestiefelt und lässt
sich von den gästen die impf zeugen zu
zeigen sie waren dabei haben müssen ja
wer welchen sinn soll das machen man
wartet hier auf dieser bühne wo im
moment so viele mit mit filz lahcen
rumlaufen mal eine figur sie sind es ja
aber dass die polizei das muss ins leben
und ist noch nicht zu ende sage ich noch
mal eine figur die eine führungsfunktion
hat die sagte macht keinen sinn mehr das
kann auch märz sein wir machen das nicht
ja dann hat die koalition keine eigene
mehrheit und dann ist es geplant oder
auch erst wenn der kanzler sagt mir dass
jetzt intensiv angeguckt ich habe
übrigens in der debatte im bundestag
beobachtet er hat interessanterweise
hätte merkel niemals gemacht sogar von
den akten aufgeschaut und hat die afg
redner beobachtet ihn zu gehört also
frau weigel zugehört und auch natürlich
um das thema ist also den kritikern mein
eindruck ist nicht festgelegt er sehen
wahrheit gar nicht entschieden ob er das
wirklich will aber er dass er mehrfach
gesagt hat er mehr als berater haben sie
im da hat er gesagt er bewegt sich im
breiten geh- es schwer da wieder runter
sausen oder
aufgrund neuer erkenntnisse müssen auch
in der lage sein unsere haltung flexibel
alles was ich was ich will ist passiert
auch richtig finde wir können nicht
sagen vor einem jahr hat er dieses und
jenes gesagt ich weiß nicht mehr was ich
vor einem jahr gesagt habe und daran
muss ich mich mein leben lang das
festhalten lassen aber es gibt in der
noch geht das mit viel zu viel
politische spielereien mir geht es um
die sache wenn wir feststellen dass die
impfung keine fremdschutz beinhaltet das
also die impfung gebucht hatte sich
nicht nur selbst anstecken konnten auch
wieder andere anstecken können wenn wir
feststellen dass die wirkung des
impfschutzes was den selbstschutz angeht
nach drei monaten zu ende ist dann macht
eine impfpflicht keinen sinn ich werde
mir trotzdem eine vierte empfohlen weil
es mich reifer ruhiger werden lässt in
einem etwas höheren alter weniger junge
frauen ansagen als aber nicht bezeichnet
genießen ich habe genug von den info
mittlerweile